i want to start with you
because i was reading that the theme of
unity
in this movie didn't emerge until later
on so it was making me wonder what was
the crux of the story before
that actually showed itself uh well i
mean the dna of the movie was always
about
unity and and uh coming together it just
there was
i think for a longest time uh before we
came on it was trying to figure out what
what would it take for them to be able
to do that and what uh
what could it be and we could we were
when we came on don carlos to myself
uh we just we were examining what it was
that really makes people
uh not want to work together it really
was mistrust
uh and and trying to write a movie that
uh honors how hard it is to trust
someone especially
if on the surface it seems like you
shouldn't um and that was a journey that
we wanted to
to to make the story about because you
know it's a it's a theme that
felt very timeless we had no idea that
in the moment
that we were making it would become so
timely
you're very very successful in that
department a big part of the reason why
i appreciate the movie so much
carlos i know the opportunity to work
over at disney kind of was an unexpected
one for you but what about the idea of
filmmaking within the animated realm in
general was that ever a path that you
thought you were going to pursue
i mean to be honest i i grew up watching
these movies i
loved animation for as long as i've been
around
um but i i just didn't really
think it was a path that i i would never
imagine that my second
movie would be a major disney animated
feature
next to uh the legendary dong hall
i i just didn't think that was possible
i it was probably
yes it was a dream of mine and i thought
that maybe when i was much more
experienced
like my 10th feature maybe i'll get a
chance to direct to disney and i'll know
enough people that someone's going to
get me in there
but this happened in a really unexpected
way
and it was one of those great surprises
that life has to offer honestly i'm so
happy there uh i'm glad i met don and
glenn mcqueen
and all the team animation has just
welcomed me so
warmly so it's been um really really
great last
two years feels important to stress that
you've made three features right now
because summertime is also great and i
can't wait for that movie to finally
come out this is true thank you very
much
uh for saying that it comes out in the
summer um
it's gonna have a a release a little bit
bigger than riots
oh yeah like that
all right don i've got a two-parter for
you right now
so this is your third animated feature
serving as director
and for all of them you've worked with
another person under that credit so
first
what do you think it is about making an
animated feature where having two
creators at the helm benefits the film
and then also can you highlight some of
the
similarities and differences between the
relationships you had with
steve and chris and now carlos um
you know it is a uh sort of a common
thing especially at disney that we have
sort of the dual director system um it's
not
um it's not a mandate by any means uh i
think it's just a byproduct of
so many different things in terms of uh
we're intensely collaborative
and so if you look at like miyazaki
um you know he is a true auteur uh he
writes his stories he storyboards his
stories and
uh basically designs the characters and
you know everything
uh and his films are amazing and we're
almost the exact opposite of that in
terms of yes we still
it still boils down to you know director
or directing team having a clear vision
but then
you know then it's we have a building
full of the most amazing artists in the
world and
and keeping that you know that
collaborative
feeling going throughout the entire
process is just that's in our dna and so
i think that's probably why you see more
directing teams you know at disney
because it's just a byproduct of
of um you know just the the way we
collaborate on these stories
um it's interesting uh that you bring up
steve and chris
and now carlos um uh you know i think
i would say the the the similarities
um with steve and chris i i had worked
with them for quite a while they became
my
good friends prior to us even directing
you know um
carlos and i had only known each other
for what maybe five months
i think before you came on uh we both
came on this movie so
um even though you know we hadn't had a
long friendship there was a friendship
there
uh even though it was sort of a new
friendship um that that was in place
before we
we jumped on and directed together and
and qui and i were working on a on
another project
in development before we came on so uh
from day one it was
there was just an ease of collaboration
amongst all of us
uh a fun um almost a mischievous fun
where we were kept you know thinking man
are we gonna get away with some of this
stuff and uh
and we just kept pushing and pushing
each other and so
uh like i said the similarities is just
sort of a a collaboration based on
friendship first and then of course that
obviously grew over the course of making
the movie
i have to follow up on that and all
three of you can chime in is there and
what is an example of something where
you thought like i don't know like can
we actually get away with making this
happen in our movie or you expected
someone to stop you at some point
i mean it was a constant game of dare i
think as soon as we jumped on because
when they were like hey
literally when uh jen was like queen don
carlos you want to take a crack at this
film you want to do this
it began with us going to basically a
small room together
and and going hey so what would we do
it's like well
here's a crazy idea and it kind of just
became
you know three mischievous little boys
just going this would be stupid if we
did this it'd be dumber if you did that
all right let's go pitch it let's see
what happens and lo and behold they let
us
do it so a lot of it just felt like uh
i mean from like you know the shooting
style to the jokes that we were making
the kind of heroes we were creating
um it it felt it felt like a nice fun
adventure to be taken with two my
buddies here probably the fight scenes
right i mean
specifically the fight scenes knowing
you know you know they're they're pretty
intense and and not just for an animated
film even for a live action film i think
they would stand up to any live action
film so
i you know and never got one ounce of
pushback i think because they were
integrated into the story and so well
crafted and choreographed by quee and
maggie
uh and the animators um never got one
ounce pushback but
you know that was always in the back of
our head is this movie gonna be too
violent
you know uh but never not one bit of
pushback
i got one um because yeah we we were
worried about the
like the fight scenes we were worried
about some of like the more darker
uh thematic elements you know a lot of
people get turned to stone
um but there was one thing that we were
positive that was not going to make the
filters and those were the farting
beetles
all right that's true yeah yeah this was
clear this was all queen
and really he tried to convince don
well it came from your mind which it
it's it's a it's a good thing
there were gophers i think when queen
they're fart gophers when i started
people the gophers turned into bugs he
presented
to don and i we're like look that's
hilarious it's obviously never going to
pass
like any filters like they're not going
to let us but sure just keep it as a
placeholder
and then we presented to jen our cco and
she's like
all right let's go for it and then we
presented to all the people
across the street just big corporate
disney no one had one note and all of a
sudden uh
here you have these uh characters whose
uh
main contribution to the movie is that
they uh floating
yeah they fart colorfully
we hope they inspire a movement of uh
i don't know what it is tick tock
glitter party put that dare out there
and it's going to happen watch when the
movie comes out
ellen's accepted thank you guys so much
for your time
thank you thank you so much appreciate
it